[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Welcome to Assistant
on Air, where we have
conversations with people that
build for Google Assistant.
I'm Jessica Dene Early-Cha
and I'll be your host today.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Actions on Google,
which means I build actions
and I create content
for developers.
Today, we'll be chatting
with Brad Abrams.
Welcome, Brad.
BRAD ABRAMS: Hey, Jessica.
It's good to be here.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Thanks for joining us.
Brad, what do you do?
BRAD ABRAMS: So I am a Product
Manager on the Google Assistant
team.
And I run a big part
of the developer
platform for the Assistant
we call Actions on Google.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Oh, that's awesome.
So what does that
mean that you run--
you run this?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes, well--
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: You're
a product manager on this.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah,
so I'm the product--
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Not
that you run the whole shabang.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, exactly.
A few engineers
watching this are
going to have questions for me.
I'm-- yeah, so I'm the product
manager for parts of it.
And really, what I do
as a product manager is
try to figure out
what developers want
to do on the platform,
like, how can they take
advantage of the Assistant?
How can we make it
easier for them?
And how we can bring in
end user requirements,
like what users want
out of the Assistant,
and match that with
what developers want.
So it's kind of a
giant jigsaw puzzle.
But I work very closely
with the engineering team.
And it's fun to work together
and build brand new products,
especially in this space.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Oh, my gosh, yes.
It's great.
BRAD ABRAMS: So
many other spaces
are mature for developers,
and we know what works
and what doesn't work.
And, in this space, the
Assistant is brand new.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Yes.
BRAD ABRAMS: It's
the wild, wild west.
Developers are figuring it
out, we're figuring it out.
And so it's kind of fun
to do, fun space to be in.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Yeah, that's awesome.
Well, speaking
about the fun stuff,
at I/O we announced a couple
of really cool things.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: So
I'd love to talk to you about
content--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yep.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
--about App Actions, and about
experiences.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: So
let's start off with content.
BRAD ABRAMS: Content.
Yeah, content is great.
So I've been on this team
for almost three years now.
And what I've
learned is that it's
hard to build
conversational experiences.
JESSICA DENE
EARLY-CHA: It is hard.
BRAD ABRAMS: I mean, let's--
it's a new domain.
It's hard for Google
to build them.
And it's even hard for
third parties to build them.
And so what we've seen
is many of these actions
actually just reflect
some underlying content
that the developer has.
And so we thought,
why don't we just
let developers give us that
content in a way that's
native for them to
give us the content
and then we'll do
the heavy lifting
of building rich, immersive
conversations out of them?
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: And that way, users
can have great user experiences
and they can work super
well conversationally.
And developers can focus on kind
of what their unique value is,
which is in that content.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: OK,
so what type of examples-- so,
if I have content, how
can I either format it
so that it's
digestible by Google?
And what type of
materials would be good?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, so the
ones that we announced at I/O
here was FAQs and how-tos.
So, for example, with how-tos,
if you have a website,
maybe how to change
a flat tire, you
can actually mark
up that website
with schema.org markup,
which has been around
for 10 plus years.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Yeah, industry standard.
BRAD ABRAMS: Industry standard.
A lot of web developers are
already familiar with it.
Literally, it's just
tagging the HTML elements
with the schema.org.
And then Google
will index that data
and build a conversation
action for you
that helps users navigate
your website in a way that's
more voice forward, more
assistive in nature.
So, on the phone, or on a
smart display, for example,
an end user can go
through there with just,
show me the next step, move
to step two, skip this step.
JESSICA DENE
EARLY-CHA: Oh, my gosh.
BRAD ABRAMS: And that's just
a much better way for users
to go through your content
in this assistive experience.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Yeah,
so it sounds like they just have
to worry about
marking up their--
BRAD ABRAMS: Right.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
--content and Google will
handle all of the natural
language processing, all that--
BRAD ABRAMS: That's right.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
--the hard part.
BRAD ABRAMS: That's
right, that's right.
And, you know, YouTube also
has a ton of how-to videos.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: I'm
on there learning things
all the time.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes, I
wouldn't be able to get
anything done in my house
if it weren't for YouTube.
And so we've also made it
possible for YouTube creators
to create these how-to
experiences that work really
well on the phone and on the
smart display with that content
that they have.
So, in this case, they just--
you go to the Actions console
and then upload a spreadsheet,
actually--
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Oh, interesting.
BRAD ABRAMS: --you just give the
URL to the video that you own,
and then the minute markers for
each step of the conversation--
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Oh, OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: --each
step of the how-to.
And then we can build out
the experience from there
that moves the video to the
right place, and whatnot.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Oh, that's nice.
BRAD ABRAMS: It's a
really smooth experience,
so I encourage
people to try that.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Oh, that's really cool.
That's fantastic.
So, in that same kind of vein,
for Android developers, people
who have their own Android
apps, we have App Actions now.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
So what does that mean?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, so I'm
really excited about App Actions
because, on the phone, we want
the Assistant to be the best
way to get things
done on the phone.
And there's-- we were talking
about mature ecosystems.
Android has a quiet,
mature ecosystem.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: It is.
BRAD ABRAMS: Everybody out there
already has an Android app.
And so we want to help users
make better use of the Android
apps they already
have installed.
So, right now, to
launch an Android app,
you have to go to the
launcher, scroll, scroll,
find it, tap on it,
navigate into the app
to get something done.
What we want to do
is shortcut that,
make it much easier for users.
You could just say, hey,
Google, send $50 to Jessica.
That would be good, wouldn't it?
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
That would be great.
Let's do that now.
BRAD ABRAMS: Everybody
should do that.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Not only
does that just sound faster,
I could definitely
imagine people who are not
as familiar with apps, that
being an easier learning
curve of this is how you just
do something with your voice.
BRAD ABRAMS: It's
much more natural.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: You know, when I
tell people how to do things,
you say, well, first you open
the app, and then you go here,
and you have to know the
way the app thinks about it
rather than the way
humans might talk, right?
JESSICA DENE
EARLY-CHA: Basically.
BRAD ABRAMS: And so
just like with content,
we've moved the burden
for dialogue understanding
to Google.
So we actually have a team
of hundreds of linguists--
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Oh, that's awesome.
BRAD ABRAMS: --that
are coming up
with all the different ways
users might say something like,
send money to Jessica.
Like, I can't come up with them.
Like, hundreds of
different ways and hundreds
of different languages.
We have people
figuring that out.
And so, once we do, we
load that into a concept
we call a built-in intent.
And so we have built-in
intent for sending money,
for ordering food, for
tracking a work out.
We launched four or
five here at I/O.
We're going to launch
hundreds of them
as we get our linguists
going on this.
And then, as a developer, you
just subscribe to those intents
or implement those intents.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: So
far an Android developer,
what are they doing?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
How much work
are we looking at for them?
BRAD ABRAMS: So we think this
is about a day's worth of work.
So we think this is something
every Android developer should
do.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: So what you do
is you open up Android Studio
and you add an Actions XML file.
It's the file right next
to the AndroidManifest,
similar to the AndroidManifest.
And, in there, it's
essentially a mapping file.
You take the set of the built-in
intent that we mentioned,
so for example, the send
money built-in intent,
and you map that to whatever
intent that is in your app.
That means it goes to
this intent, whatever
page of your app makes sense.
And then you write a
little bit of Java code
to handle the arguments
that will patch you.
We'll patch you the amount,
and the person's name,
and so the app developer parses
those and then pre-populates
the UI and sets it up.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
That sounds fantastic.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: I'm
super excited to see-- just
be able to talk to my
phone to open things up,
get things done a lot faster.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, hopefully
it'll be a lot faster for users
to get things done.
JESSICA DENE
EARLY-CHA: Very cool.
So the last thing
which I'm really
excited about because-- it's all
about the experience and more
the conversation side.
BRAD ABRAMS: That's right.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: So
I'd love to talk to you about
Canvas--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, so--
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: --and
that amazing experience.
BRAD ABRAMS: I love Canvas.
So for people that are building
conversational actions today,
they've mainly been voice
focused and not had any UI.
And that works well
for Google Home device.
But on the phone or on a
smart display, it's not great.
And so, in the past, we've had a
handful of cards you could use,
so three or four different
cards, which is good.
But we wanted to offer a much
more immersive experience.
Specifically, we want to--
we've been looking at games.
Like most new platforms, games
are a big use case for us.
And for people that are building
games for the smart display,
we wanted to give them
a lot more flexibility.
And so we thought,
what's a great UI
technology that works on every
device and scales beautifully?
You know, the web is
pretty good at that.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
It is really good.
BRAD ABRAMS: That's kind
of been figured out, right?
So we thought, let's
just let developers
use the knowledge they already
have, HTML, CSS, JavaScript,
but they get to execute
that on the client, so
on the smart display device.
And then you attach a
conversational action to that
so that, at any stage
in the conversation,
I can click a button on the
screen or I can just say that,
and the UI moves forward
or the game moves forward.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
That sounds awesome.
BRAD ABRAMS: So we
think this is going
to unlock, really, a
whole new set of use cases
and really rich,
immersive experiences
for that smart display.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Something you just reminded me
of--
I think of children
playing games.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
So many times
when they're playing games,
they're yelling at the game.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Because
that's the most natural--
BRAD ABRAMS: Exactly.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
--way that we do things.
BRAD ABRAMS: And now the
game can understand them.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: I
know, that sounds so great.
BRAD ABRAMS: So it's
good, it's good.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Oh
my gosh, that's awesome.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah,
I'm looking forward
to seeing what developers
come up with with Canvas.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
I know, right?
Oh, my gosh.
That's exciting.
So it sounds like there's
also just a different way
of thinking of how
to build as well.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, so
it's a state based model.
So developers actually
think about, what
are the different parts
of this conversation?
What's the flow of this
conversation going to be?
Users were first asked
this, and then they'll
move to this, and then to this.
And then, as a developer,
you can actually
model those as states
in your application
and the transitions
between them.
And then Google actually
helps with the human language
understanding part
of this and how
they move between those states.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
That sounds great.
Because I know from a
developer point of view,
just the state experience makes
a lot more sense to me versus--
not that [INAUDIBLE]
isn't great.
I love that tool.
It makes a little more sense--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
--from my point
of view, which is great.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So yeah, we're super
early with this.
We're just in an
early preview of it,
but we're hoping developers pick
it up, give us feedback, tell
us what works and doesn't work,
so that we'll be ready when
we launch it for developers.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Yes,
that sounds really exciting.
Speaking of feedback--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
--how can developers
give you feedback on any of
these and all the things?
BRAD ABRAMS: Well, we--
my team and a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] hangs out on Reddit,
on our Google Assistant
developer channel on Reddit.
So that's a great place to post.
Love to hear your stories about
what's working and not working.
And then also, I'm on Twitter.
So I'm BradA at Twitter,
so please tweet at me.
Let me know what's working
and not working there.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Oh, that is awesome.
BRAD ABRAMS: I'd love
to hear your stories.
So please feel free to do that.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Thank you so much for coming
and also just to
offer all of that.
Because not everybody
understands, necessarily,
the importance of
getting that feedback
and making our products better.
So thank you so much
for taking the time.
BRAD ABRAMS: No, thank you.
I enjoyed being here.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Yeah, thanks.
Awesome.
So thank you so much, and
if you liked today's show,
please like this video.
If you have any comments
or suggestions on what
you want to learn in
the future videos,
please comment below and
feel free to follow us
on Twitter, Actions on Google,
and we use the hashtag aogdevs.
And there, that's where we post
our updates and new episodes.
I have been Jessica.
Chat with you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]